[Music]
the problem in society we have at the
moment is everyone is afraid of making a
mistake
what may happen if we don't do anything
the pandemic has changed life as we know
it
but what comes next will our fast-paced
lives pick up again
will we continue to innovate regardless
of the cost
live limes profit driven
and globally connected
or has this pandemic sparked irrevocable
change
hello and welcome to the show this week
we're thinking about life after the
pandemic
we're asking experts in areas like urban
planning climate change and even
nutrition
to tell us what they've learned so far
and what those lessons mean for the
future
today we look at crisis management and
begin with a report
from taiwan located near the airport
taurian hospital was one of taiwan's
gatekeepers against the virus
authorities had stand a fifth of
confirmed cases here
for treatment since the start of 2020
but in january this year an infected
doctor triggered the fresh outbreak
several of his co-workers were later
tested positive
taiwan faced its biggest coronavirus
crisis
since the start of the pandemic your
neck are not jesus
hospital acquired infection is very
serious and hard to control
patients in the hospital need health
care workers to take care of them
they're next to each other it's
impossible to just quarantine hospital
workers and leave patients alone
wong works at the central epidemic
command center
he soon decided to set himself up in the
hospital to directly oversee
communications
from the command center
we had to contain the virus
in a large hospital of more than 2 600
employees and around 700 impatiens
one wrong decision could lead to the
tragedy similar to the 2003
sars outbreak then the government locked
down
a hospital where even healthy people
were not allowed to leave
leading to 154 infections
and 31 deaths it was okay when there
were only one or two cases in the
hospital
but when there were more and more people
confirmed positive we were definitely
nervous
we were afraid of getting phone calls in
the middle of the night hearing about
yet another new case
this time the command center reacted
quickly
tracking all possible contacts and home
quarantining over 4
300 people they also transferred
negative test patients to other
hospitals
to decrease the workload on staff after
14 days with no new confirmed cases
all hospital employees had to do mass
testing to convince the public that the
hospital
is safe in 44 days the outbreak was
contained
with only 21 cases and just one death
transparency and honesty is very
important
and you have to give the people the
reason why you want to have
a very stringent contation and very
stringent home quarantine
and this and the evidence we have to
show the evidence that it is very
very useful to prevent the future
pandemic
chance that no countries can fight alone
i
would like to re-emphasize the important
thing is the prudent surveillance
we have to keep eye on the possible
outbreak in all
the countries to prevent its spread out
now taurian hospital is back to relative
normality
the stars experience reminded government
and its people
not to let history repeat itself a
lesson not only for taiwan
but for the world in its approach to
tackling this fast spreading virus
martin reese is co-founder of the center
for the study of existential risk
an interdisciplinary research group
focused on studying and developing
strategies
to risks that could threaten humanity
martin it's good to have you on the show
first of all
let's start with the pandemic before we
talk about talk about
existential risk rather i can barely
even say the word um we just saw about
taiwan and how its management of the
pandemic has been shaped by sars
but at the same time other countries
have had their own experiences with
infectious diseases
and yet they've struggled in their
management of the pandemic why do we see
that it differs so much from country to
country
well i think we in the uk had prepared
for an influenza pandemic
but of course we didn't have the
experience of sars and of course
uh coronaviruses need different
preparations they need protective
equipment for everyone
and it's hard to develop a vaccine etc
so we in the uk were badly prepared as
uh i think in some respects were uh
other european countries
um and i think the uh taiwan
had a government that was more trusted
perhaps than our uk government was by
its people and that do you helped
that we're worse long-term planners than
we believe we are potentially or do we
just lack imagination or is it a
combination of both
um i think we are worse long-term
planners um
obviously we can't predict when a
pandemic would strike but no one could
say it was unlikely
uh given that we had sars and mers
in the past and i think there are some
lessons we can learn obviously
one is that it pays to build in a bit of
slack in the system or resilience i mean
for instance i know
in germany you had more empty beds in
your
intensive care wards than we normally
have we try and keep them full
all the time which means you've got no
spare capacity and
also um we shouldn't depend so much on
supply chains
for manufacturing because if you have
just one long chain and one link breaks
that screws up a lot of manufacturing
so i think we've learned that it's more
important to have resilience
than maximum efficiency okay so perhaps
we're not the best long-term planners
for things like pandemics even though
actually they're quite likely
what about for truly existential threats
what you're focused on that could be
anything i gather from
a more serious illness to an asteroid
potential asteroid strike
what does that mean for planning for for
those threats
well of course you can't they're just
extremes and i should say that uh
with herman astronomer i'm not kept
awake at night by
asteroids threats etc because they are
small threats and no bigger now than
they were for the dinosaurs
very rare but the threats that we do
worry about
are those which are caused by humans um
either
collectively changing the climate and uh
causing mass extinctions etc
or by misuse of powerful technologies
bio and cyber etc
so those are the things we worry about
and uh they
will give us a bumpy ride through this
century they could cause a
complete extinction though i think
that's frankly very unlikely we're
concerned with these
extreme risks which we need to prepare
for and going back to um
uh the clovis vit19 it's going to cost
the world
at least 20 trillion dollars over the
next few years
and in that perspective and given it
wasn't that unlikely
we should have spent probably hundreds
of billions of dollars
in the kind of preparation making sure
that uh we monitor
all the places where the disease can uh
transfer from humans
to animals to humans etc and to be more
prepared and to stock up on
protective clothing and all that we've
learned our lesson that it's worth a
bigger investment to be more prepared
that investment that preparation that
readiness that always comes
with other costs not just money for
example but there are certain social
costs
um that come with that as we've seen
with the pandemic as well just
responding to the crisis
that's been a great cause in terms of uh
social well-being perhaps in terms of
economic well-being for for livelihoods
have we
have we fully measured the social and
economic impacts of the pandemic and
what does that mean for our planning for
crises
well we haven't and i think one possibly
uh benign effect of the
copic crisis is to realize how important
workers are not just a direct in the
health service
but delivery drivers carers and people
like that
uh who in our system um are under
supported poorly paid and in insecure
jobs and i think
uh one lesson we ought to learn is to
minimize or reduce inequalities which
have been actually accentuated
by the pandemic and people like myself
for instance can go on working
from home etc but many people can't and
those who are in
cramped apartments with no gardens etc
have had a really tough time so i think
the experience of the pandemic has
accentuated
the effect of inequalities which many of
us think are far too great anyway
and i hope to be pressured to reduce
them
martin reece is co-founder of the center
for the study of existential risk i'll
get that word right eventually martin
thank you so much for joining us thank
you very much
well our science correspondent derek
williams is also thinking about the
future
here he is with a question on the future
of mrna technology
we came up with vaccine for covid in
under a year what do developments like
that mean for the future of healthcare
covet 19 vaccines represent an
absolutely
immense achievement in the midst of a
raging pandemic
governments and pharma companies and
scientists
came together to produce vaccines at
lightning speed to fuel the biggest
vaccination drive in history which is
now progressing
at an astonishing pace um additionally
the coronavirus has triggered an
absolute
avalanche of research that's already
having ripple effects on areas
far far beyond health care
sars kovi 2 has promoted even closer
cooperation
between science and industry while
at the same time revealing glaring
weaknesses
in health care systems it's also exposed
um the many many ways that it's possible
for governments
to mess up communications with the
public despite all that we've gotten
wrong
though i remain positive overall and
and i think that history will look back
on these years where
where so many lost so much
as as the first time that humanity came
together
on a global scale to fight a problem
that threatens us all covet 19
has sparked advances in a really wide
range of fields
but i want to focus on one advance in
particular
that experts say will change health care
in fundamental ways and that's messenger
rna technology in cells
mrna is the molecule that allows
information from the archive of the
genome
to be turned into into the physical
metabolic
reality of proteins and and controlling
and tailoring proteins is a tool of
incredible power
scientists have been trying for decades
to harness
the mrna information system to fight
a huge range of diseases then the
pandemic hit
and all that hard work ended up
turbocharging the development and the
launch of the
mrna vaccines now in use the first
ever to be approved that's released
the floodgates i think and and we can
expect more vaccines
based on the platform to hit the market
in the next couple of years
including highly individualized vaccines
that help your immune system for example
zero in
on cancer mastering mrna
will allow us to shift treatments for
many diseases
away from today's approach which is to
to mitigate
symptoms with medications and towards
addressing
the real roots of diseases and that's
huge
[Music]
and that's it for today's peak in the
future check back with us tomorrow
thanks for watching stay safe
see you again